hey guys so uh this past week I got to
go to london and i went to london for
the europe next up camp i got to hang
out with all of the winners we got to
make videos we got to collab and pretty
much just have a good time and make
videos all weekend you guys are shooting
a little zombie video why are you not a
zombie guys shoot movies on me do I get
to help shoot him yeah not only did it
get to make some fun videos with all of
the winners but I did get a chance to go
and do some touristy things as well I'm
lost I'm lost
a lot of you guys have been asking me
Justine where's all your videos from
London well my friends I made a playlist
of all of the videos which you can find
below and if you can't find those below
here's an annotation for you and if you
happen to be on your mobile phone you're
just going to need to figure it out and
to all of you who I had a chance to meet
in London it was amazing meeting you I
absolutely love doing meetups and
getting to see you guys and talk to you
and take pictures that seriously is the
highlight of any trip of any event is
meeting you people and realizing that
you're real people who watch these
videos who comment and getting to take
pictures and give you actual hugs in
real life is by far the most amazing
thing ever anyway let's get watching
those London videos playlist here
playlist here go